cette voie que vous entendez celle de
thomas pesquet l'astronaute français
était en direct ce jeudi 17 juin avec
l'université paris saclay la séance de
questions réponses a été suivi en temps
réel par quarante élèves du lycée saint
françois d'assise de montigny le
bretonneux depuis l'observatoire de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines et
ça c'est émouvant quand même parce qu'en
fait on fait qu'il en direct et tout ça
après et puis il n'y avait pas
énormément de personnes en plus donc
c'était 7 est vachement c'était
vachement bon par exemple nous a dit de
toujours saisir les occasions
la connexion à dure au total dix minutes
pas une de plus le cône finalement et
dans lequel avec lequel on peut
communiquer une certaine une certaine
taille
c'est compliqué surtout quand il ya
beaucoup de monde nous nous on fait ça
régulièrement parce que on a notre
propre talent satellite et notre propre
antenne mais c'est à chaque fois un
challenge malgré tout de recevoir la
commune de faire la communication avec à
sa tête avant cette retransmission des
animations avec des interviews il ya un
jeu ont été organisées objectif mieux
comprendre la vie de thomas pesquet à
bord et pourquoi pas susciter des
vocations
c'est un secteur qui fait rêver mais
c'est aussi l'occasion de montrer que
voilà il ya une multiples métiers de
compétences et participer au
développement du spatial aux sciences du
climat et de l'atmosphère est quelque
chose qui est complètement dans l'air du
temps
la journée s'est terminée par une visite
de l'observatoire de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de quoi avoir
des étoiles plein les yeux en rentrant à
la maison